[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit die
serien ihnen allen guten abend das
wichtigste vom sport heute wieder mit
zwei und forst und auch von mir einen
schönen guten abend auch heute sortieren
wir die aktuellsten und wichtigsten
ereignisse in der ukraine
russische truppen beschießen in der
ukraine das größte atomkraftwerk europas
die bilder sorgen weltweit für besorgnis
die internationale gemeinschaft ist
höchst alarmiert über den krieg in der
ukraine beraten die außenminister der
nato und der eu auch heute eine
krisensitzung nach der anderen
währenddessen versuchte russland jede
kritische stimme im land mundtot zu
machen
[Musik]
europa warte heute morgen mit einem
schock auf in der nacht hatte russlands
militär das größte kernkraftwerk des
kontinents in der ukraine angegriffen
dass der krieg auch für mitteleuropa
folgen haben könnte wurde dadurch sehr
konkret der meiler ist jetzt offenbar
unter kontrolle unter russischer fünf
kernkraftwerke gibt es in der ukraine
das bekannteste tschernobyl ist
stillgelegt zwei aktive liegen im
nordwesten des landes ein drittes ganz
im süden und es gibt eben das jetzt
angegriffene sa borussia mit sechs
reaktoren hat es die größte kapazität in
ganz europa christoph distel
noch nie in der geschichte ist jemand
dieses risiko gegangen kämpfen und
schießen rund um ein atomkraftwerk
letzte nacht war es soweit plötzlich
brennt es die lage scheint außer
kontrolle der sprecher des kraftwerks
schlägt alarm
warnung streitkräfte der russischen
föderation feuern auf das atomkraftwerk
subotic ja es besteht die reale gefahr
einer nuklearen bedrohung des größten
atomkraftwerks in europa
am morgen dann vorsichtig entwarnung die
ukrainische feuerwehr hatte den brand in
einem ausbildungszentrum der anlage
löschen können heißt es radioaktivität
sei nicht ausgetreten der ukrainische
präsident ist trotzdem außer sich
diese anlage hat soviel
gefahrenpotenzial wie sechs tschernobyls
und die russischen panzer wussten genau
dass sie das akw gelände beschießen dass
es terror auf eine noch nie dagewesene
art
doch während ein französisches
kamerateam die verletzten ukrainischen
kämpfer in einem krankenhaus filmt
präsentiert russland seine version der
ereignisse man habe das akw gelände
schon vor tagen eingenommen sei gestern
nicht angreifer sondern verteidiger
gewesen
letzte nacht das war eine monströse
provokation russische wächter wurden von
ukrainischen saboteuren attackiert und
mussten darauf antworten das glaubte im
westen keiner aber die angst vor einer
atomkatastrophe geht um drei der sechs
blöcke liefen während des beschusses
momentan soll es noch einer sein aber
grundsätzlich besteht bei
kernkraftwerken immer diese hauptgefahr
stromausfall denn dann könnte auch die
wasserkühlung für die brennstäbe nicht
mehr laufen sowohl im reaktor als auch
in den abklingbecken für alte stebe
ungekühlt könnten die feuer fangen und
so radioaktives material frei setzen und
im reaktor selbst würde eine
kernschmelze drohen andere gefahr eine
direkte bombardierung der akw
gegen einen expliziten militärischen
angriffs sind sie aber sicher nicht
ausgelegt das heißt bei einem
tatsächlichen beschuss der
reaktorgebäude müssen wir auch
befürchten dass es zu massiven schäden
kommt die akute strahlungsgefahr in
sabaudia halten fachleute für gering
aber durch das erste gefecht um ein akw
scheint plötzlich manches undenkbare
denkbar
wir fragen nach bei katrin eigendorf für
uns in der ukraine kathrin ukraine
präsident spricht von nuklearem
terrorismus sagte sei selbst angegriffen
worden was können sie berichten
nun die ereignisse liegen jetzt ziemlich
klar auf der hand das kraftwerk sa paris
ist von russen angegriffen worden
das feuer ist unter kontrolle gekommen
aber nichtsdestotrotz ist die situation
so dass die ukrainische regierung sich
große sorgen macht dass russland hier
noch zu weiterem nuklear terror greifen
könnte erstaunlicherweise ist die
bevölkerung hier relativ ruhig und nicht
in panik ausgebrochen obwohl wir hier
nur 600 kilometer entfernt sind von
separieren und 140 kilometer entfernt
von uns ein weiteres atomkraftwerk ist
ich denke wenn man sich die ereignisse
an guckt muss man auch im hinterkopf
haben dass putin damit ganz sicher auch
auf europa gezielt hat denn die welle
der sympathie und der rückhalt für die
ukraine und ihr eintreten für irland
soll glaube ich aus putins perspektive
jetzt in angst umgekehrt werden denn bis
jetzt waren es ja vor allem die uca und
sind es die ukraine die unter diesem
krieg leiden aber ein nukleare
katastrophe würde natürlich europa
treffen und das hat entsprechende angst
wirkung danke für die einschätzung
katrin eigendorf
eine weitere schwere kriegs nacht steht
bevor und die vergangene war auch wieder
heftig raketen und panzer beschuss im
südöstlichen mario pohl wo der
bürgermeister verzweifelt um
militärische unterstützung bittet
heftige attacken auch in hf und die
hauptstadt kiew muss sich auf das
schlimmste gefasst machen russlands
militär versucht nach ukrainischen
angaben die stadt einzukesseln luton
linus
die hölle des krieges erreicht kiew
bilder aus kosten einer siedlung direkt
am stadtrand ein video der ukrainischen
seite das russische verluste zeigen soll
beim versuch in die hauptstadt
vorzurücken heute
haben ein ziel das ist auch statt die
hauptstadt hat eine symbolische
bedeutung das ist die hauptstadt
unterbreiten
und das ist herz du meine und deswegen
die russen versuchen wird das ist
okay zu machen sie wollen ihre stadt
verteidigen freiwillige errichten an
vielen stellen in kiew panzersperren und
barrikaden wird das reichen den gegner
aufzuhalten
ich weiß nicht ob das klappt ich bin
kein general wir werden es versuchen
deshalb sind wir hier
andere suchen ihr heil in der flucht zu
groß sind die ungewissheit und die angst
vor dem was nun kommen wird
die große frage die wir nicht
beantworten können
wird die russische armee versuchen kiew
in anführungszeichen auszuhungern oder
wird man den strom auf tier vorbereiten
das heißt häuserkampf letzteres würde zu
einem unglaublichen blutbad in dieser
stadt führen tag 8 des einmarsches
bringt kaum russische geländegewinne
neben kiew stehen karte für mittelpunkt
und das eingeschlossene mario pohl aus
dem es heute keine bilder gibt die
millionenstadt karachi fliegt weiter
unter beschuss im norden der stadt
schlagen fast stündlich raketen und
granaten ein so augenzeugen und die
bomben liegen direkt in die wohnhäuser
also von den russen kann man jetzt von
offiziellen also politikern
inoffiziellen berichten kann man hören
lesen dass die drucken noah
militärobjekte beschießen das stimmt
nicht in lemberg in der west ukraine
berühmt für seinen weltkulturerbe haben
sie begonnen wichtige statuen und andere
kulturgüter zu verpacken und vor dem
krieg in sicherheit zu bringen
während in der ukraine weiter gekämpft
wird gibt es immer wieder diplomatische
bemühungen heute hat bundeskanzler
scholz mit dem russischen präsidenten
putin telefoniert und ihn zu einer
waffenruhe aufgefordert schon vorher
hatte scholz eine beteiligung der
bundeswehr ein weiteres mal
ausgeschlossen beim
einsatzführungskommando im
brandenburgischen schwielowsee sagte er
wir sind nicht teil der militärischen
auseinandersetzung die dort stattfindet
und werden es auch nicht werden
auf allen westlichen politischen ebenen
und kanälen stimmt man sich gerade über
den russland ukraine krieg ab in brüssel
haben sich die außenminister der eu und
der nato beraten was könnte man
diplomatisch noch erreichen welche
sanktionen noch hängen und was wenn es
weiter eskaliert die krisensitzungen im
blick hat ina baltes
familienfoto so heißt das traditionelle
gruppenbild aller nato außenminister und
die militär familie war sich heute
eigentlich wie selten die nato darf
nicht in den krieg eingreifen
wir unterstützen die ukraine aber die
nato ist nicht teil des konflikt die
nato ist ein verteidigungsbündnis wir
suchen nicht den krieg mit russland
die lage in der ukraine so die nato
werde sich in den kommenden tagen noch
verschlechtern trotzdem eine
flugverbotszone
der wunsch aus kiew werde es nicht geben
denn dazu müssten nato-flugzeuge
russische maschinen abschließen am
mittag reisen alle auch der us
aussenminister die zehn kilometer weiter
zur eu angeli blinken würdig die
beschlüsse der eu als historisch
auch hätte niemand für möglich gehalten
was jetzt realität ist die couch diese
zone ist stark steigend und sie hand
gleitet
nun sollen weitere sanktionen
beschlossen werden auch im rahmen der
wichtigsten industrienationen g7 der
krieg verschärft sich weiter den
politischen westen lässt das enger
zusammenrücken
wer russlands politik kritisiert der
bekommt das sehr schnell und sehr hart
zu spüren die letzten verbliebenen
unabhängigen medien werden abgeschaltet
und es geht noch weiter heute wurde ein
gesetz verabschiedet wer aus der
perspektive moskaus fake news verbreitet
muss mit langjährigen haftstrafen
rechnen mehr von goliath
jede kritik unterbunden jeder
widerspruch verboten die
berichterstattung über russlands cri cri
faktor unter strafe gestellt russlands
parlament verbietet nicht nur anti
kriegs kundgebungen es verbietet alles
das den einsatz der streitkräfte
diskreditiere und droht mit
freiheitsstrafen von bis zu 15 jahren
diese us-firmen wie instagram und andere
werden ganz klar als waffe genutzt sie
erzeugen feindschaft und lügen die
müssen wir uns wieder setzen und unsere
streitkräfte schützen
einige abgeordnete tragen ein z an
revers oder auf ihrer kleidung der
buchstabe der auch auf russlands panzern
auftaucht ist offenbar ein kennzeichen
der operation gegen die ukraine für das
verteidigungsministerium ein symbol für
die sogenannte
entnazifizierung
zeitgleich zur duma sitzung
durchsuchungen bei häussler zeltes der
menschenrechtsorganisation memorial
die ist zwar längst aufgelöst ihr wird
aber weiterhin terrorismus vorgeworfen
ich hoffe dass russland nicht untergeht
aber die aktionen der russischen führung
bedrohen die integrität des landes das
ist mehr oder weniger klar für alle die
über die zukunft russlands nachdenken
durchsuchungen und beschlagnahmungen
auch bei der
flüchtlingshilfsorganisation der
alternativen nobelpreis trieren swetlana
gannuschkina auch sie konfrontiert mit
dem vorwurf des extremismus die heute
verabschiedeten strafgesetze empören sie
das ist alles monströs die heutige
politik der krieg den wir führen ist
zerstörerisch für den staat für die
gesellschaft für den staat als ganzes
auch wenn tausende nun russland
verlassen swetlana gannuschkina will
bleiben
gehen wir nach moskau jetzt zu christian
seinem christian wie ist dieses neue
gesetz einzuschätzen was bedeutet es für
die arbeit von journalisten in russland
ja das ist ein weiterer schlag gegen die
pressefreiheit hier in russland haben
zum beitrag gerade schon gehört bis zu
15 jahren haft drohen wer
falschmeldungen über die russische armee
verbreitet und was heißt das genau ja
das weiß man eben nicht das gesetz ist
wie so oft das haben wir schon öfter
erlebt bei anderen restriktiven gesetze
so schwammig formuliert dass man gar
nicht genau weiß in welchem rahmen man
sich da bewegt das gesetz soll vor allem
russische journalistin und journalisten
treffen die er in den letzten tagen auch
massiv attackiert wurden in dem gesetz
steht aber auch dass das gesetz auch für
ausländer gilt und so herrscht auch bei
den internationalen journalistinnen und
journalisten hier große aufregung was
denn eigentlich noch erlaubt ist die
britische bbc hat jetzt erste
konsequenzen gezogen und wird erstmal
nicht mehr mit ihren korrespondenten aus
russland berichten und passend zum thema
meinungsfreiheit kam eben kurz vor
unserem gespräch noch eine andere
meldung dass russland facebook
blockieren wird danke für die aktuellen
informationen nach moskau christiansen
hunderttausende fliehen derzeit aus der
ukraine die allermeisten ins benachbarte
polen seit ausbruch des krieges sind
dort mehr als 700 tausend flüchtlinge
angekommen das ist eine enorme
herausforderung und wie die bewältigt
wird und womit in zukunft zu rechnen ist
dazu henner hebestreit
ständig kommen mehr menschen aus der
ukraine nach polen wo die behörden die
lage gut im griff haben private und
staatliche helfer kümmert sich rührend
um die flüchtenden aus dem nachbarland
für manches polen durchgangsstation die
meisten aber haben keinen eigenen
anlaufpunkte woanders in europa und
stranden in notunterkünften oder hotels
wie diesem
es ist sehr hart sich einzugestehen dass
du darüber nachdenken muss dir hier ein
neues leben aufzubauen
an einem absoluten nullpunkt
dem du nichts hast gar nichts
der krieg hat julias leben über nacht
auf den kopf gestellt sie verdiente gut
war viel gereist doch jetzt den job und
die schöne wohnung vergangenheit sie
lebt auf 7 quadratmetern im hotel
es gibt welche die haben verwandte aber
einige ziehen auch in wohnungen oder
häuser in szeged diese unterkünfte
werden von der stadt oder vom staat
organisiert es melden sich aber auch
viele privatpersonen die wohnungen
bereitstellen
die hilfsbereitschaft der polen ist
riesengroß private sachspenden helfen
über die ersten tage hinweg und die
regierung richtet sich bereits darauf
ein noch viel länger für die geflohenen
sorgen zu müssen als die gehofft haben
alle die wir das land oder die
heimatstadt verlassen haben dachten doch
wir sind bald ganz bald wieder zu hause
nach einer woche oder höchstens zwei
weil eine so schnelle rückkehr
unwahrscheinlich ist will polen jetzt
2500 sozialwohnungen an ukraine vergeben
und bereitet sich darauf vor für noch
viel mehr menschen aus dem nachbarland
da sein zu müssen
auch in deutschland kommen immer mehr
menschen aus der ukraine an knapp 19.000
hat das innenministerium seit beginn des
krieges registriert vermutlich sind aber
mehr es gibt bislang keine zentrale
erfassung die erste station nach
tagelanger zug oder busfahrt ist für die
allermeisten berlin
am hauptbahnhof kümmern sich zahlreiche
freiwillige um die geflüchteten
versorgen sie mit essen trinken bieten
aber auch unterkünfte an
angesichts des leids im kriegsgebiet ist
die hilfsbereitschaft in deutschland
riesig viele fragen sich allerdings wie
sie am besten helfen können mit
sachspenden oder doch lieber geld
spenden was kommt an was wird überhaupt
gebraucht isabel de la vega jetzt mit
einem überblick die hilfsorganisation
gain hat in gießen einen spendenaufruf
gestartet das echo ist riesig alle
wollen den ukrainern helfen wir packten
im moment vor allen dingen hygienepakete
das sind die ganz normalen dinge drinnen
wie zum beispiel zahnpasta zahnbürsten
seife kann es gibt unzählige solcher
initiativen da werden lebensmittel
gesammelt und kleidungsstücke von
hilfsorganisationen aber auch
privatpersonen die mit transportern an
die grenze fahren viel engagement aber
die hilfsorganisationen sehen auch
probleme ich sehe es da kriege ich das
einmal dinge mitgenommen werden die vor
ort nicht gebraucht werden zum anderen
sind an der grenze natürlich sehr sehr
viele menschen unterwegs viele die die
ukraine verlassen wollen und man kommt
dann als einzelperson da gar nicht durch
wer eine geprüfte organisation mit
partnern auf der ukrainischen seite
sucht kann sie im internet unter dz idee
finden
geldspenden helfen am besten weil man
damit dass kaufen kann was vor ort
benötigt wird ganz zielgerichtet und in
der menge und in der anzahl die man da
die man benötigt viele würden auch
flüchtlingen aus der ukraine ein zimmer
zur verfügung stellen unterkunft ukraine
de ist eine bundesweite
vermittlungsplattform allerdings bevor
man ein bettenangebot macht sollte man
sich im klaren werden dass es hier nicht
darum nur darum geht ein dach über dem
kopf zu geben sondern dass man auch den
menschen im sozialen sinn und auch
vielleicht bei amtswegen und auch bei
der integration helfen sollte ganz neu
ist auch die online plattform jockey
ukraine kommen auf der man geflüchteten
jobs an
fast 52 millionen euro sind schon
zusammengekommen für das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe und wenn sie den
menschen in der ukraine und denen auf
der flucht auch helfen möchten dann
können sie das weiterhin mit der u bahn
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 stichwort
zdf nothilfe ukraine alle infos dazu
auch auf spenden
punkt.de oder auf der ctf textseite 890
ja gut eine woche krieg hat natürlich
auch wirtschaftlich deutliche spuren
hinterlassen der spritpreis auf
rekordniveau der gaspreis in europa ist
so hoch wie nie exporte die wegbrechen
und auch die börse schüttelt sich an
diesem freitag am ende der handelswoche
sina mainitz in frankfurt welche bilanz
ziehen sie er leider eine äußerst
düstere wochenbilanz anleger stellen
sich nach dem angriff auf das
ukrainische atomkraftwerk inzwischen die
bange frage welche folgen der krieg
vielleicht noch haben mag die
ungewissheit vor dem wochenende führt
zum ausverkauf an der börse der dax
verliert binnen einer woche zehn prozent
und kann sich zum schluss nur noch knapp
über der drei zehntausender marke halten
e10 benzin kostet durchschnittlich einen
euro 93 war heute aber pro liter auch
zwischenzeitlich über zwei euro und der
weizenpreis liegt knapp 40 prozent zu
das verteuert auch viehfutter den
ärmeren ländern drohen hungersnöte
ökonomen senken ihre wachstumsprognose
für deutschland dieses jahr erheblich
und sehen zunehmend das risiko der
stagnation also wirtschaftliche
stagnation bei gleichzeitig steigenden
preisen normalerweise haben
geopolitische spannungen nur einen
vorübergehenden einfluss auf die
rohstoff und aktienmärkte dieses mal
könnte es anders aussehen danke nach
frankfurt sina mainitz und zur situation
in der ukraine gibt es auch heute wieder
ein zdf spezial gleich im anschluss an
unsere sendung und immer auf dem
laufenden sind sie mit der zdf heute app
wir schauen noch auf ein anderes thema
der us elektro bauer tesla kant noch in
diesem monat mit seiner produktion in
brandenburg beginnen das land hatte die
endgültige genehmigung erteilt
allerdings unter umfangreichen auflagen
unter anderem zum schutz des wassers
tesla hatte in den vergangenen zwei
jahren die fabrik in der nähe von berlin
errichtet auf grundlage von einzel
zulassungen dort sollen rund 12.000
beschäftigte bis zu 500.000 autos pro
jahr produzieren
weiter mit corona da warnt das robert
koch-institut dass der scheitelpunkt der
omicron welle bei den senioren noch
bevorstehe auch steigen die zahlen
insgesamt wieder schauen wir uns mal an
das lka registrierte 217 1593
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
6850 mehr als vor einer woche
da kommt die zahl 291 todesfälle kamen
innerhalb eines tages hinzu die sieben
tage incidents jetzt bei
1196 vier und damit leicht erhöht im
nordwesten pakistans haben zwei
selbstmordattentäter einen
bombenanschlag in einer moschee verübt
mehr als 50 menschen wurden getötet etwa
200 verletzt nach angaben der polizei
waren schiitische gläubige gerade beim
freitagsgebet als die beiden männer die
moschee stürmten und sprengsätze
zündeten bislang ist unklar wer für den
anschlag verantwortlich ist
zwölf tage nach den olympischen spielen
sind in peking die paralympics eröffnet
spiele die unter dem eindruck des
krieges stehen in russland und belarus
sind ausgeschlossen und einige der
ukrainischen sportler sind nur mit mühe
aus ihrem land herausgekommen ulf röller
über eine eröffnungsfeier die im
schatten des krieges stattfindet
es sind nur noch wenige minuten bis zum
größten moment in ihrem sportlerleben
das deutsche team vor dem auftritt
eigentlich ein tag der freude aber die
welt lage ist dramatisch
ein bisschen befremdlich und auch
schwierig sich jetzt auf das wesentliche
einer sportveranstaltung zu
konzentrieren während jetzt da die post
abgeht
in bunten bildern inszenieren sie bei
der eröffnungsfeier eine heile welt
menschen mit und ohne behinderung tanzen
vereint doch die spiele sind
überschattet vom krieg in der ukraine
präsident schienen die invasion putins
eine spezialoperation
und dann der auftritt der ukrainischen
mannschaft die geballte faust in den
himmel ein wunder dass sie hier sind
wir sind nicht hier um sportliche
erfolge zu erzielen wir kämpfen für den
frieden für alle auch für irland vor
york an erst nach langem zögern
entschloss sich das internationale
paralympische komitee
russland und belarus auszuschließen umso
entschlossener der appell des
präsidenten andrew was uns jetzt ein
wort das alles sagt
die deutsche mannschaft nimmt beim
einzug ins stadion kurz die mützen ab
und formt mit den händen das
friedenszeichen eine kleine geste für
ein großes drama
so und wir machen sportlich weiter mit
wintersport svenja und mit biathlon in
kontiolahti beim letzten staffelrennen
der saison waren die deutschen männer um
erik lesser lange zeit auf podestkurs am
ende reichte es in einem spannenden
vierkampf aber nur zu platz vier
deutschland war ganz nah dran an einem
podestplatz schlussläufer philipp
nawrath fehlte nur eine sekunde zu rang
reicht von beginn an die staffel denkbar
knapp startläufer erik lesser hatte bei
dem letzten staffelrennen in seiner
karriere mit null fehlern vorgelegt
übergab als elfter auf roman rees er
hatte hier vorher so bist du natürlich
gewünschten ausgemalt aber das ist ja
wenn du so aufgeht habe ich mich sehr
gefreut als dritter ging benedikt doll
in die loipe insgesamt mussten die
deutschen achtmal nachladen doch vier
schießfehler von schlussläufer nawrath
für deuten am ende platz vier das wieder
bis zum schluss mit vier mannschaften
beweise und hätte jetzt nicht ganz
unerwartet aber wieder spannend war die
drei stehen die
ärgernisse gewonnen hat norwegen vor
schweden und frankreich
und in oslo fand heute das erste mixed
skispringen seit den olympischen spielen
statt in peking war wegen zu großer
anzüge auch das deutsche team
disqualifiziert worden heute landete das
quartett um katharina althaus markus
eisenbichler juliane seyfarth und
schlussspringer karl geiger auf platz 5
der sieg gegen überlegen rand
olympiasieger slowenien
und mehr wintersport im zdf livestream
schon ab 3 uhr in der früh mit dem
paralympics aus peking unter anderem mit
ski alpin und biathlon ab 9 uhr geht es
dann im zdf weiter mit ganz viel
weiteren wintersport und kurz zum
fußball die bundesliga partie am sonntag
zwischen mainz 05 und borussia dortmund
findet nicht statt der grund ist ein
corona ausbruch bei den mainzern dazu 05
sportvorstand christian heidel
begründung ist dass das wir stand heute
noch 14 spieler
einsatzfähige spieler haben darunter
aber keinen keinen
spielberechtigten bundesliga-torhüter
und nachholtermin ist mittwoch der
sechzehnte märz was ist für zeiten
dankeschön sven zum wetter im westen
sonnig im osten eher trüb und für alle
kühl mehr gleich von katja schäfer ich
empfehle marietta slomka und das
heute-journal ab 22 uhr 10 und das
spezial gleich nach und das gesamte
heute team wünscht einen angenehmen
start ins wochenende
morgen an dieser stelle barbara hey
danke und auch bald
[Musik]
guten abend das hoch martin sieht morgen
weiter in richtung irland für uns
interessant ist aber dass hoch lino an
unserem wetter ändert sich wenig es
bleibt bei einer kalten nordöstlichen
strömung da ziehen auch nebel und
hochnebelfelder zu uns rein das gilt
auch in dieser nacht im westen ist es
dagegen klar und der wind weht meist nur
ganz schwach aus östlichen bis
südöstlichen richtungen die temperaturen
sinken auf null grad auf rügen und bis
-10 grad am alpenrand und morgen bleibt
es sehr kühl bei uns vor allen dingen in
der osthälfte da steigen die
temperaturen nicht über zwei bis fünf
grad hinaus im westen wird es mit fünf
bis zehn grad etwas milder aber längst
nicht so mild wie noch in den
vergangenen tagen morgen halten sich
zunächst nebel und hochnebel aber bis
zum mittag sollte die sonne dann doch
eigentlich überall den durchbruch
geschafft haben und den ganzen tag über
scheint sowohl vom sauerland bis zum
altmarkt an diesem wetter wird sich auch
in den nächsten tagen wenig ändern im
osten ist es kälter als im westen und am
montag könnte es hier im erzgebirge mal
für ein paar schneeflocken reichen wie
sie aber hier am trend für köln sehen
können werden wir die frostigen nächte
wohl erst zum nächsten wochenende los